the Prime Minister may be aware of Sky
news's investigation and report today on
the over-the-counter sales of nitrous
oxide or laughing gas to children and
young teenagers one alarming aspect is
the change in the size of canisters from
8 grams to 620 grams and ambulance call
outs related to overuse of tripled
instead of criminalizing the young
people who buy nitrous oxide isn't it
time to take urgent action against those
knowingly selling this harmful and
potentially life-changing substance to
children under age
I Thank The Honorable lady for her
question I share her concern in the
concerning members across the house
about nitrous oxide's detrimental impact
on communities it's contributional to
antisocial behavior and indeed I
mentioned it in the speech I made at the
beginning of this year specifically The
Advisory Council on the misuse of drugs
is conducting a review of nitrous oxide
and is looking particularly at this
question the Home Secretary has asked
them to expedite their review and we
will consider their advice carefully
when it is received